Peter I want to start with you because
my understanding is that this script
came after a bout of writer's block for
you what was going on and how did this
story help you out of it I wouldn't say
I was blocked because I had jobs and I
was doing those jobs but I had I think
I'd lost my confidence and I felt that I
well not to be political but I felt
after the election I felt particularly
helpless and and at very great variance
with my my family not my immediate
family but my family that I grew up with
that lives all over the country and I
just felt that I needed I just wasn't
telling stories I had to tell and both
of our boys were are now men and they're
raised and they're off in the world and
I felt what if what if I put all the
energy that I've been putting into
serving other work which I've been proud
of that work but what if I looked really
deep in myself and and found something
that I felt I had to make as if this if
this would be the last thing I would
make in the world what would it be and I
looked at all of the projects I've been
working on and and I knew I wanted to
write about the heroin opioid epidemic
I'd lost too many people we're losing
too many people but I also wanted to
write a love story about the love where
someone won't give up on another person
and I thought it was going to be a
sister with a brother and I was writing
and it was going fine but the minute I
said what if it what if with the person
to go into the underworld will was this
young man's mother
mm-hmm it it just took off and it
started to write me Julia yeah
[Applause]
thank God he changed from his sister to
mom no kidding yeah there's only so much
you can do with a face mask you can get
Dewey but you can't get 20 what do you
remember that it was that grabbed you
when you read it for the first time well
I guess it was just I thought how
incredible and I don't think I've talked
about this with Peter sitting right next
to me thank you Peter but I just thought
how incredible that Peter has taken
something that is this monster that has
overcome overwhelmed all of us in some
way and he has turned it into this human
fragile document this one day this one
family I just thought how extraordinary
and as though that isn't interesting
enough he decided he who seems so gentle
kind and sensitive said so scares let's
make it Christmas Eve morning to
Christmas morning when there's nothing
on anybody's family plate let's let's
put it there and I just thought god this
is so moving and incredible and what
everyone needs to be brought back into a
conversation that has gone on for so
long that it's kind of gone away
I think Teddy what did it take to make
this financially viable was it Julia and
Lucas hedges was it the story was it a
combination of all of the above
definitely a combination of all the
above I mean I think for for our company
we try to look for projects that have
meaning that are adding something to the
world and yet also have some level of
commercial potential to sound somewhat
crass and I think this was a film that
you read and you just sort of felt in a
weird way that it it had it had
something incredibly important to say
just about the opioid crisis what's
affecting families around America around
the world and yet there's something
incredibly relatable about the story
even if you don't have exposure to
addiction even if it's something else
that affects your family and I think
watching as a mother or a parent does
everything in their power in order to
keep their family safe in order to keep
their family on track even if you know
that you can't actually affect that
outcome it's such a relatable and human
instinct and it was something that maybe
as a father of three maybe just
imagining Julia in that role felt like
something where you'd be able to deliver
the underlying message of what this film
was addressing but do it with sort of a
package that lulled people into a false
sense of security and I think from a
from a production standpoint you know it
was looking at the body of work of Peter
who both as an exceptional writer an
incredibly talented director had done
some really amazing work in the past but
I think it was really it took it took
someone like Julia Roberts saying that
this was important to her and that she
was going to make the sacrifices that
were necessary to make an independent
film when she can do probably anything
that that she wants to say that this
story matters and I think without that
none of us would be sitting here I was
so surprised to learn that the casting
of your son Lucas in the role was not
kind of like this foregone conclusion
like it was actually a process to agree
to have him do it and to get him
interested and I think he kind of had to
hear that actors that are in his peer
group were reading it and thought it was
a great script for him to think oh maybe
I should do it oh yeah I wrote this
knowing that he would not do the film
why isn't that like a great dad to write
the best
ever and be like I know you don't want
to do it was probably something a bit
insidious I was there I think I've been
busted
I will admit no um I he he for an actor
so early in his career has worked with
remarkable list of directors and none of
them get to be his father and and he
just wants me to be his dad he doesn't
want me to be as director and I respect
that but he heard the joy you wanted him
to do the film he I we wanted to make
this film as quickly as we could it's
that great John Wooden line be quick but
don't hurry so we were trying to be
quick because I wanted as soon as we had
it done to put it out I didn't want to
worry about any of the things that I
mean we're here at the Academy I just I
just want this film out so that people
it can be a part of a conversation that
like Julia said that we need to be
having so he wasn't available and I knew
and I was writing it and he so even if I
wanted him to do it he wouldn't be
available when I met with Julia she said
Lucas needs to do the film I had a list
of actors and she never even let me show
her the list so he heard that she really
wanted him to do the film the the the
play he was to be doing on Broadway he's
doing a different plan Broadway now but
he was supposed to be doing an another
play a year ago that play went away so
he he became available and he did start
to get texts from these prominent young
actors who were going to come in and
audition saying did your dad wrote this
first of all he's like weed yeah but I
guess anyway they were they your dad
wrote a really good script but I think
what he really wanted was to read it in
to support me to say good job keep going
and when he read it and and I think
honestly when he considered that I'm
Carol hedges son my mother
was an alcoholic she walked out the door
when I was said alcohol walked her out
the door when I was seven and I didn't
know her sober till I was 15 um we
nearly lost a relative of mine
I think truthfully because Lucas had
just done boy erased he and which he's I
think amazing in and he needed a break
but I think he really felt that this
story and mattered
and but he also he was very cognizant of
it for the healing aspects in my own
family that Carol had his grandson Carol
hedges who was nearly dead when I was 15
before she went to the third rehab that
my sister went through rehab with her my
non-drinking sister who had cancer at
the time went through I mean it's like
amazing story I went his Christmas is
gonna be like yeah but anyway and this
is too long of an answer and I'd really
rather hear Julia talk so I'm gonna
quickly say that that he gave me an
amazing gift and I love watching these
two actors together
it was Newman and Redford it was matthau
and lemmon it was and and they were the
thing that and I really just have to say
that I studied with Sanford Meisner I
I'm not a good actor but I know great
actors and I know when they're great and
the greatest actors are generous and
Julia was so generous with Lucas and he
was generous with her every major scene
in this movie I could have given you six
or seven different versions of that
scene if I have any regret it's that I
didn't have the capacity to see that
they've nailed it by take-two
and a lot of times I apologize public my
regret I'd say why don't we do it again
sometimes it was because it was just so
frigging enjoyable to watch them go at
it Julia one of the reasons I think this
is one of my favorite performances that
I've ever seen you give is its mama
epitomised and and I like that ferocity
and fragility that's a great combination
what allowed you to find that and did
you feel good as you were doing it like
do you feel like okay I'm kind of firing
on the set all the cylinders or do you
never allow yourself I am nailing it day
18 day 27 I never happened it never
happens that's the hold that's the
carrot that can dangle 'z for 30 years
yeah you're waiting for someone to get
inside your head and go yeah it never
happens but that's the good news the you
know for me the best part was that going
into this endeavor I knew we had the
document I knew it was all there on the
pages and really it had so much to do
with Lukas and myself and which had so
much to do with Peter letting me in
those whatever how many few few days
that we had to film let me be the parent
you know Lucas called Peter Peter and I
called Peter Peter and and and somehow
Peter knew how to not get between the
mother and the son and still talk to the
actors so that to me was very special
and unique and I adore Lucas in every
way and felt completely safe with him
and I felt that I could you know hug him
and kiss him and punch him in the face
and do all the things required and Peter
just let us do that so that's that's how
we made this movie in the freezing cold
winter what a pleasure it is to be with
all of you guys so please help me thank
Teddy and thank you so much